you've never done that before when you
got one one one one one with space I was
trying to guess and the space it sounded
like some sort of [ __ ] Filipino thing
you know that's how we tell Filipino
voodoo and all the sudden like No
welcome to the another episode of I'm
your slept King yo whatsapp do you know
I'm urban Bobby - what's up brah what's
up yeah yeah yeah yeah no don't do that
don't make that face okay so we got
Gilbert here flat face sir love them
flat brown and beautiful we got we got
kalokhe kalila my girlfriend my life
partner mm-hmm I mean [ __ ] yeah bro we
got this white piece of [ __ ] right here
man and I'm on to you man all right
you're [ __ ] desert-y bro I mean a
desert the desert white it's very away
yeah but they're shifty out there in the
Mesa in the minute their love plateaus
of cooking up stuff right there in
trailers you know and he's got his
[ __ ] shady cousin right here now damn
Bryce whose name is Bryce that's [ __ ]
black toe sure bro shut the [ __ ] up man
I love it I love you mom but we got a
very special guest that's gonna throw
out some of his credits he's in a new
movie on Netflix called tremors 2-6 say
that wrong number no III thought there
was only one tremors five before okay so
my bad I told you at the time no all
right oh yeah yeah but I won't say go
back he was in a lot of movies Malibu's
Most Wanted scream but he's in one of my
favorite movies all-time Bowfinger great
[ __ ] movie
don't you love Bowfinger quite a kind of
just say this though my left eye was in
him not yet okay and I was in a movie
with him called kickin it old-school and
that's how I met Michael Rosenbaum
that's how him and I became friends and
Jamie basically got me of that movie
okay so give him a round of applause
Jamie Kennedy everybody
dr. Han now you can [ __ ] talk yeah
what up buddy yeah that was weird I was
scared like you were like don't say
anything until yeah but now you're
talking okay thank you yeah and I a
complimented your ears I liked your ears
appreciate that
you're welcome point I want to tell you
something how so he was doing this movie
kicking an old school and I remember
reading and I thought it was okay but
the guy like the producers didn't want
me and then you made it happen you're
not coming one more time you're gonna
read it from this guy right and I
remember you being like super like just
careful you didn't say it you really
wanted me to get it you're very clear
when you're reading it with me and then
when I was saying my lines I remember
you kind of sang the lines you don't
mean mouthing mouthing it with me
because he doesn't want me to [ __ ] a
pageant mom yeah yeah yes one of the
lines and then next thing I know I get
it and I'm gonna say this on all of my
career and I haven't had that big of a
career it's okay
don't great stop no it's fine but great
I'm just saying that that shooting that
movie was by far the best time I've ever
had in any movie or TV show of all time
really yeah really why I don't want to
hear right it was shot in Vancouver yeah
we're staying at the Sutton Place yeah
and that's when he still insists on
staying at the fond memories of oh yeah
I have you guys hell we ha I do I had a
great time yeah this [ __ ] in place this
is yes Lutton place yeah and here's
another thing it was when oblivion came
out other squirrels right so they were
like gays where I just didn't work at
all but you know you're still out there
shooting the movie so I just I bought an
Xbox question and I just never left the
Sun place I just the drapes
yeah that's what you were doing yeah
well you thing I was jerking off that
was times we could not get yeah really
that's what I was doing do you think I
was doing whoring it up no yeah you're
sober yeah but you were just you know it
was like you're well you got very high
energy and then you like I I can relate
to that and then when you sleep you
wanna you're dead so I thought maybe
he's just chilling but there were times
where you wouldn't come out yeah I
wouldn't come out at all he would not
come out and I didn't know that you were
elder scrolling it yeah I was out of
scrolling it and also Wow yeah you know
and they also kind of just say this tell
me what I want to know why it was a good
time I'm listening
because on when you're shooting first of
all when you're shooting with that group
of people
mm-hmm there's just I mean I'm sorry but
there's no pressure
yes I agree no in a bad way I did it
well comfortable yes when I was with
friends and even like Maria Menounos was
super nice she was in it if we have
pictures yeah what's her name right yeah
come on you know her name no no yeah
yeah and I met what was that one
breakdancing coach we are oh oh
Shabba legend its let just Nick chopper
do shabba-doo do yes Hobbit legend
legend legend you know he's turbo no yet
something no he's always only you guys
no song no bro Mesa you don't know I was
raised me okay my one of my first
probably beech tree was at my first
hip-hop movie I ever saw probably
breaking in a second and he was the
dancer the great-looking guy he was
ozone he was the star of it go through
like a dance bootcamp big-time big-time
so I wanted to do this movie and I had
these other dance instructors from
another movie and they said yeah that's
not I think with this dude and so we
went into a dance boot camp we got she's
got a pretty good synchronicity ish yeah
I guess but it was intense but keep
going side yeah yeah and then so out of
talk yeah say whatever you want oh I
didn't know you said don't yeah no no I
just point hey [ __ ] yeah at this point
you can say whatever you want okay yeah
so we did the movie and I created like
like I became friend
with him I became friends with Rosie and
I became friends with a couple of guys
even that what's that fat Mexican that
wasn't it
era great guy great guy great guy I just
called fat Mexican and then he used to
come to the comedy store yeah yeah
afterward like after we shot yeah like
every day for a year
that's sweet to hang out yeah sweet yeah
I know you know I talked to Miguel all
the time he just texted me I'll get
Miguel New Year's was he was what
jambalaya man wasn't he was I'd you
wanna yeah I love that movie
agent theme the Cajun theme right yeah I
saw him on a airport the airplane I
walked past him he was in first class
yeah and I go it's up and he didn't man
no yeah so now he dish you he just kind
of looked at me like no yeah he did she
didn't diss me he was just like that
doesn't sound like not a dish yeah I go
hey what's up Miguel right and he looked
up he has legs crossed you know how
fancy blacks do that yeah fancy black
might get in trouble for that
yeah am I gonna get in trouble for that
alright it's a cat food brand yeah yeah
yeah click on the ones and tons that
consider right second city bro
that was MIT though that yeah I learned
it the first DVD set I ever bought of a
show Jamie Kennedy experiment
ah yeah he's sneaking in the love it's
time not it
[Music]